la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
thème automobile tout électrique 2035
est-ce réalisable
et la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat
Monsieur Serge babary
vous avez la parole pour le groupe les
républicains pour 8 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en juillet 2015 la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale
présidée par notre collègue le sénateur
Jean-François Husson évaluer le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air pour la France entre 67 et 98
milliards d'euros par an
à ce chiffre s'ajoute le bilan humain
selon le ministère de l'écologie il
s'agirait de 48 000 décès prématurés par
an 9% de la mortalité en France en
octobre dernier le Conseil d'État
condamné l'État français à payer deux
nouvelles astreintes de 10 millions
d'euros en raison du dépassement des
valeurs maximales fixées par les
directives européennes
le trafic routier est responsable de 28%
des émissions totales de gaz à effet de
serre en France dont la moitié
proviennent des véhicules des
particuliers aussi la transformation du
secteur automobile est certainement un
élément clé de la transition climatique
encore faut-il que la restructuration de
la filière soit réfléchie dans son
ensemble et les objectifs à signer
réalisables depuis les années 2000 la
filière automobile française réduit ses
capacités de production nationale le
solde commercial des échanges extérieurs
du secteur est passé d'un excédent de 13
milliards d'euros en 2004 un déficit de
15 milliards d'euros en 2019 dans le
même temps l'industrie automobile
allemande augmenter son excédent
commercial de près de 30 milliards
d'euros
la filière automobile a également subi
une succession de crises conjoncturelle
avant la crise sanitaire la filière
constructeur comme équipementier
fournisseurs représentés environ 400 000
salariés plus de 10% exportations de
bien pour 3/4 à destination l'Union
européenne et plus de 20 milliards
d'euros de valeur ajoutée la crise
sanitaire a eu un impact significatif
sur l'industrie automobile avec une
diminution de la production en France et
une chute des exportations en 2021 la
sortie de crise a été perturbée par les
difficultés des fournisseurs à
s'approvisionner en matière première et
en composant électroniques cette
année-là 11 millions de véhicules n'ont
pu être produit en octobre dernier le
chiffre de 4,5 millions était avancé
pour 2022 enfin dernièrement il y a eu
la guerre en Ukraine et la crise
énergétique parallèlement à ces crises
conjoncturelle la filière fait face au
défi de la décarbonation en développant
depuis 2018 l'offre électrique le 8 juin
2022 a été franchi la première étape
vers la fin au l'Union européenne des
véhicules thermiques le Parlement
européen en effet voter la révision des
normes des missions de CO2 pour les
véhicules particuliers et utilitaires
légers dans le cadre du paquet
ajustement à l'objectif 55 pour 2030 le
texte adopté exprime le soutien des
députés à la proposition de la
Commission visant à atteindre une
mobilité routière à émission nulle d'ici
à 2035
le 28 juin 2022 sous la présidente
française la deuxième étape était
franchie les ministres européens de
l'environnement ont en effet convenu le
relevé les objectifs en matière de
réduction des émissions de CO2 pour les
voitures neuves et les camionnettes
neuves d'ici à 2030 à 55% pour les
voitures et à 50% pour les camionnettes
ils sont également approuvé
l'introduction d'un objectif de
réduction des émissions de CO2 de 100%
d'ici à 2035 pour les voitures et
camionnette neuves fort heureusement une
clause de revoyure a été ajoutée pour
tenir compte des développements
technologiques selon Marc mortueux
délégué général la plateforme automobile
française les dépenses de recherche et
développement de la filière en France
représente environ 7 milliards d'euros
par an à l'occasion des travaux menés
par la commission aux affaires
économiques sur la filière automobile
c'est celui-ci nous a assuré que les
choses sont lancées il faut réussir nous
n'avons pas le choix on y est c'est
irréversible
des inquiétudes sont pourtant nombreuses
le premier risque identifié touche à
notre souveraineté en France les
véhicules électriques et hybrides
rechargeables ont représentés près de
18% de Dimitri immatriculation 2021
alors qu'elle ne représentait que 3% en
2019 il y a actuellement 60000 véhicules
électriques en circulation en France
alors qu'il en faudrait un peu plus de
15 millions en 2035 comment s'assurer
que ces véhicules seront fabriqués en
France en Europe qui ne seront pas
importés de payer étrangers comme la
Chine
pourra-t-on produire en France les
batteries et les bornes de recharge par
ailleurs la production des véhicules
électriques et dépendante de
l'approvisionnement métaux rares tel que
le cobalt le lithium ou le nickel or la
France et l'Europe ne sont pas
producteurs de ces métaux à l'occasion
de la séance de questions gouvernement
du 12 janvier dernier Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Économie a évoqué son
souhait de rouvrir une usine de lithium
les Français sont-ils prêts à ouvrir des
mines et à accueillir ce type d'usine
sur leur territoire a-t-on les
compétences pour le faire
pourrons-nous respecter les délu
Européens aura-t-on le temps d'implanter
des entreprises de fabrication de bornes
de recharge
se pose également la question de
l'énergie et du bilan carbone des
véhicules électriques
pour calculer la quantité de CO2
produite par une voiture il faut tenir
compte non seulement du CO2 émis pendant
son utilisation mais aussi des émissions
causées par sa production et ensuite sa
destruction la production et la
destruction d'une voiture électrique
sont moins respectueuses de
l'environnement que la production et la
destruction d'une voiture équipée d'un
moteur à combustion la manière de
produire l'électricité et donc cruciale
les atermoiements des précédents
gouvernements sur le nucléaire nous ont
conduit au risque de coupure
d'électricité avec le zéro
artificialisation net pourront nous
mettre en oeuvre les projets de centrale
nucléaire annoncés
en 2035 pourrons-nous alimenter les 15
millions de véhicules annoncés avec de
l'énergie bas carbone ou son obligé
d'importer une énergie carbonée produite
à l'étranger
la France n'aimait qu'entre 0,9 et 1,5 %
des émissions mondiales de CO2 quand la
Chine est responsable de 29% les
États-Unis le
14%. ce chiffre est en grande partie du
au fait que la France a délocalisé ses
émissions de CO2 il ne faudrait pas que
la brièveté du délai imposé nuisine
Finet au bilan carbone des véhicules
électriques sans compter que nous ne
savons pas recycler des batteries de ces
véhicules lorsqu'il y en aura 15
millions en circulation sur le
territoire français qu'en ferons-nous
enfin tous les citoyens entrepreneurs
pourront-ils bénéficier de cette
révolution il y a les barrières du coût
d'achat et d'usage le déploiement des
bornes de recharge mais aussi de
l'évolution technologique à l'instar des
camions présents sur les marchés par
exemple de nombreux véhicules
utilitaires et professionnels n'ont
aujourd'hui pas le homologue en
électrique ces véhicules bénéficiaires
ont-ils de dérogation en cas de ZF
comme nous l'avons fait en matière
d'énergie ne faut-il pas accepter qu'il
y ait un mix je pense ici à l'hydrogène
mais aussi aux innovations sur le moteur
thermique il existe des études notamment
australiennes sur la dépollution du
moteur diesel faut-il se priver de ces
formes d'innovation l'électrique
est-elle la solution universelle
toutes ces inquiétudes nous invitent à
ne pas confondre vitesse et
précipitations cette politique doit être
conduite au bénéfice de notre économie
et de l'équilibre de notre société et
être pensé avec les entreprises pour nos
concitoyens la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique doit être une
chance pour l'économie française et non
l'occasion de valoriser des économies
étrangères
avec mes collègues du groupe les
républicains nous avons conçu ce débat
comme un point d'alerte
alerte à ne pas reproduire les
atermoiements et erreurs commises en
matière du nucléaire alerte à ne pas
adopter des mesures qui enfermeraient
notre économie et exclure toute forme
d'innovation alerte enfin à veiller à la
cohésion de la société sans marginaliser
une partie de nos concitoyens le tout
électrique soulève de nombreux enjeux en
matière d'infrastructure le souveraineté
industrielle et de lutte contre les
inégalités sociaux économiques le
présent des balles doit être l'occasion
de réfléchir ensemble à une stratégie à
long terme je vous remercie
merci beaucoup merci la parole est à
Madame Olivier agrégoire ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du tourisme pour une durée de 8
minutes maximum
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
président babary mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs la voiture de demain sera
électrique les voitures électriques
continuent de se faire une place de plus
en plus conséquente dans les ventes de
voitures neuves de l'Union européenne
1,1 millions de véhicules électriques
qui ont été vendus en 2022 c'est 28% de
plus en une année elle représente au
total 12,1% des voitures neuves vendues
en 2022 contre 9,1% en 2021 ou encore
1,9% en 2019 selon les chiffres publiés
par l'association des constructeurs
constructeurs européens en France c'est
même un taux supérieur avec 13,3% des
véhicules vendus qui était entièrement
électrique en 2022 soit 200 000 sur les
1,5 millions de véhicules vendus
derrière ces chiffres je souhaite
profiter de ce débat pour porter trois
messages clés sur le développement du
véhicule électrique en France la voiture
électrique est indispensable essentiel
pour décarboner notre secteur des
transports dans son dernier rapport le
GIEC alerte sur l'urgence climatique il
reste quelques années vous le savez pour
agir éviter les pires conséquences d'un
changement climatique non maîtrisé pour
les générations futures et les années
qui sont devant nous sont décisives pour
déployer des solutions qui nous
permettent de contenir ce réchauffement
en deçà des deux degrés Celsius le
véhicule électrique en tant que solution
d'ores et déjà disponible et mature fait
partie des leviers absolument
indispensables et d'ailleurs d'après le
GIEC je cite les véhicules électriques
alimentés par de l'électricité à faible
émission offre le plus grand potentiel
de décarbonation pour le transport
terrestre
les émissions du secteur des transports
qui pèsent pour 25% des émissions en
Europe et pour 30% des émissions en
France ne baisse pas et même au
contraire continuent d'augmenter plus 12
% entre 1990 et 2015 en cause la
dépendance au carburant fossile le
maintien d'un niveau élevé des missions
par véhicule mais aussi la croissance
des trafics la fin des voitures
thermiques et la conversion à
l'électrique sont donc des leviers
absolument essentiels une étape dans le
chemin vers une mobilité décarbonée
l'interdiction de la commercialisation
des véhicules thermiques à compter 2035
en Europe à le mérite de la clarté une
voiture électrique achetée en 2022 et
conduite en France et mes 5 fois moins
de CO2 que sont homologue à essence
grâce à une électricité produite
essentiellement à partir d'énergie
nucléaire mais aussi renouvelable source
d'énergie bascarbonne ailleurs en Europe
c'est également en moyenne trois fois
moins d'ici 2030 l'empreinte carbone des
véhicules électriques est amenée à se
réduire encore grâce à une électricité
de plus en plus produite à partir
d'énergie bas carbone mais aussi de
l'amélioration de la performance
environnementale des batteries
le gouvernement travaille à bâtir une
filière industrielle complète pour les
véhicules électriques cette
décarbonation vous l'avez mentionné
monsieur le sénateur babary ne doit pas
se faire au détriment de l'industrie
française c'est une évidence il faut que
la France prenne sa part dans le
renouvellement du parc automobile
français on ne peut pas importer
massivement des véhicules électriques
fabriqués dans d'autres pays le
président de la République l'a rappelé
encore lors du Mondial de l'Automobile
d'octobre dernier nous avons une
stratégie pour faire de la France une
grande nation de véhicules électriques
et pour maintenir une industrie
automobile forte souveraine en France
produire 2 millions de véhicules
électriques par an en France en 2030
ainsi que les composantes stratégiques
de leur chaîne de valeur batterie
électronique mais aussi logiciel borne
de recharge je parle ici de l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur nous devons
réussir à maîtriser les technologies de
pointe qui vont des moteurs électriques
jusqu'aux batteries en passant par les
composants électroniques de puissance et
les systèmes qui vont servir au véhicule
automatisés par ailleurs le maintien de
la localisation sur sur le territoire
national des usines d'assemblage de
véhicules est absolument primordial pour
notre filière automobile d'excellence et
pour tous ceux qui contribuent et lors
du Mondial de l'Automobile les
constructeurs renaultistes et lentis ont
ainsi annoncé l'affectation de 15
nouvelles modèles de véhicules
électriques dans leur usines françaises
l'État met des moyens sans précédent
pour atteindre cet objectif d'une
production annuelle de 2 millions de
véhicules électriques à horizon 2030
nous mobilisons via le programme France
2030 pas moins de 5 milliards d'euros
pour l'ensemble de la filière automobile
à la fois pour soutenir bien sûr la
recherche chez le développement mais
aussi pour l'industrialisation des
véhicules et de leurs composants en
France troisième élément clé le
gouvernement reste très vigilant sur les
impacts industriels et sociaux de
l'arrêt de commercialisation des
véhicules thermiques en 2035 l'arrêt de
la commercialisation des véhicules
thermiques dès 2035 est un tournant
majeur pour la filière automobile la
décarbonation du parc automobile 20 dans
le sens de l'histoire et nous sommes
prêts évidemment à soutenir tous les
acteurs dans cette mutation industrielle
il est indispensable d'accompagner nos
entreprises mais aussi les salariés de
les former dans cette révolution pour en
faire pour faire en sorte pardonner moi
que la France garde une industrie
automobile performante et souveraine
plusieurs activités liées au thermique
vont naturellement décroître avec des
impacts dans certaines filières de
sous-traitance certains impacts majeurs
le décolletage la fonderie fonte la
forge sont par exemple des activités qui
vont faire face à des baisses de
commandes dans les prochaines années
l'état accompagne ces entreprises dans
leur projet de diversification soit vers
le véhicule électrique soit en dehors de
la filière automobile parce qu'il y a là
aussi des reconversions possibles outre
les entreprises sont aussi nos
territoires qu'il faut accompagner dans
l'évolution du tissu industriel et c'est
bien pourquoi l'État a mis en place en
lien évidemment avec la banque des
territoires un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt dénommé rebonds industriels
dans le cadre du programme que vous
connaissez bien territoire d'industrie
une enveloppe de 100 millions d'euros
est déjà dédiée à aider les territoires
impactés par les mutations du secteur
automobile pour identifier des projets
industriels dans les bassins d'emploi
affectés mais aussi garantir à chaque
salarié de l'industrie automobile des
perspectives d'emploi dans son bassin de
vie mais aussi dans des secteurs
d'avenir vous le voyez donc mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs l'État est
conscient de la révolution que nous
avons à mettre en oeuvre ensemble et met
tout en oeuvre pour accompagner la
filière automobile dans cette
décarbonation absolument stratégique
bien sûr l'objectif est ambitieux mais
il n'est plus le temps de tergiverser
les décisions d'investissement des
entreprises se prennent aujourd'hui et
elles doivent être orientées clairement
en faveur de l'électrification de notre
parc automobile nous aurons loisir d'en
parler lors de ce débat auquel je
répondrai avec la plus grande acuité
possible je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
du débat chaque orateur dispose de deux
minutes maximum
y compris l'éventuelle réplique le
gouvernement dispose pour répondre d'une
durée équivalente le gouvernement aura
la faculté si le juge nécessaire de
répondre à une réplique pendant une
minute et l'auteur de la question
disposera alors à son tour du droit de
répondre pendant une minute et la
première question est à Monsieur Daniel
salmon
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l'Union
européenne a fait de la motorisation
électrique un axe central de son paquet
mobilité la fin de la vente des
véhicules thermiques 9 est pour 2035 et
15 ans après en 2050 les émissions du
parc effectif de véhicules devront être
au régime de la neutralité carbone les
batteries bien entendu sont une priorité
de relance et de mutation de l'industrie
automobile le marché de l'électrique
décolle reste qu'au rythme actuel de
leur renouvellement si l'équipement
voiture restait similaire à celui
d'aujourd'hui nous ne parviendrions pas
en 2050 à la neutralité de plus la seule
conversion électrique ne répond pas à
tous les enjeux en particulier la
réduction de la pollution par les
particules fines liées à la pression des
chaussées à l'usure des pneumatiques les
enjeux de réduction de l'empreinte des
matériaux employés pendant la pour la
construction qui constitue 75% du bilan
leur durée de vie leur recyclage leur
empreinte sociale aussi
dans les mines lointaines aux conditions
indignes des enjeux sur la nécessaire
mutualisation des automobiles pour
accroître leur temps réel d'usage et
diminuer leur nombre le nécessaire
report modal vers les transports
collectifs pour agir sur la congestion
vers les mobilités actives aussi pour
qu'elles donnent tous leurs potentiel le
gouvernement a-t-il donc au-delà de la
mutation électrique des moteurs la
volonté de conduire en même temps la
mutation des usages en se donnant les
moyens de réduire la place de
l'automobile et de de l'auto-solisme
dans nos mobilités et puisque nos
constructeurs s'enfèrent en misant
essentiellement sur les SUV laissant de
fait l'espace à la conscience étrangère
pour les véhicules électriques légers
qui s'imposeront demain le gouvernement
a-t-il la volonté de contrecarrer cette
dérive qui mine l'avenir de notre
compétitivité industrielle et de nos
emplois
si madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur salmon vous abordez plusieurs
sujets au sein de cette même question
d'abord
rappeler que contrairement à d'autres
secteurs je le disais en discussion
générale effectivement les émissions du
secteur des transports continuent
d'augmenter en cause la dépendance au
carburant fossile le maintien d'un
niveau élevé des missions par véhicule
et la croissance des trafics c'est donc
cette conversion à l'électrique est un
levier essentiel et c'est bien l'objet
de notre débat aujourd'hui et même avec
l'arrêt de la commercialisation des
véhicules thermiques en Europe en 2035
il en restera et vous l'avez mentionné
encore énormément en circulation on
estime d'ailleurs que la moitié du parc
automobile français soit 20 millions de
véhicules sera encore carbonée en 2035
il nous faut donc accélérer la pardon la
décarbonation du secteur des transports
par exemple et je pense qu'on en
reparlera en misant beaucoup voire plus
sur le rétrofit
c'est à dire notre capacité à remplacer
un moteur thermique par une propulsion à
moindre émission par exemple avec un
moteur électrique ou un moteur à pile
combustible à hydrogène cette opération
reste encore chère pas assez massifié et
donc nous sommes en train de travailler
en ce moment même notamment avec le
ministre des Transports Clément Beaune à
la à la démocratisation du rétrofit pour
faciliter la conversion du parc
automobile dans les prochaines années
pour les 20 millions de véhicules qui
resteraient encore carbonés en 2035 je
précise d'ailleurs mais vous avez dû le
voir que l'État a lancé entre novembre
2022 et janvier 2023 une consultation au
sujet du rétrofit pour récolter les
propositions des industriels du
rétrophile de véhicules particuliers
nous sommes en train du moins le
ministre de l'Industrie mais aussi le
ministre des transports sont en train
d'étudier toutes ces propositions et
vont bientôt communiquer sur un plan
d'action courant mars ça devrait
permettre ensuite à des particuliers
comme nous le souhaitons de convertir un
coup moins élevé et de façon plus facile
dans des garages sur nos territoires à
nos particuliers de pouvoir convertir
leur véhicule thermique en véhicule
électrique pour la deuxième partie de la
réponse je suggère de vous faire une
réponse écrite je vous remercie merci on
va respecter vraiment le temps parce que
nous avons un autre débat ensuite
monsieur salmon vous avez 19 secondes
merci madame le Président effectivement
madame la ministre vous avez insisté sur
les trofit qui est fort intéressant
parce qu'il permet de ne pas gaspiller
l'énergie grise qui est contenue dans
une voiture c'est forcément un élément
essentiel par contre on ne pourra pas
faire l'économie de la sobriété d'usage
et de la sobriété de dimensionnement
ainsi qu'un d'aménagement du territoire
qui permettent de revoir nos mobilités
un petit peu de temps je le prends et
sans le gâcher juste vous dire quand
même que sur votre la lutte contre
l'auto solide ou la promotion du
covoiturage au choix le travail est en
cours et Clément bonne le ministre des
Transports a annoncé un plan à votre
disposition si vous souhaitez qu'on en
parle ensemble en tout cas le plan est
lancé et nous l'avons dans le viseur je
vous remercie monsieur salmon c'est bon
je me réjouis et je suis tout à fait
enclin à participer et à échanger avec
vous sur ce sujet du covoiturage puisque
des comptages qui sont faits à l'entrée
de Rennes Métropole par exemple indique
que sur 100 véhicules aux heures de
pointe le matin il y a 102 personnes de
transporter c'est-à-dire 98 véhicules
avec une seule personne à bord donc il
suffirait de covoiturer pas tous les
jours mais simplement une fois dans la
semaine on aurait pu aucun embouteillage
aux portes de la ville donc voilà il y a
des solutions il va falloir faire en
sorte que ce qui fonctionne bien sur le
long le long trajet avec blablacar pour
le citer arrive à fonctionner au
quotidien avec des lignes de covoiturage
il y a des expériences qui sont en cours
également sur cette métropole et
j'espère que ça va se développer au
niveau national parce que c'est une
vraie solution pour limiter les
embouteillages parce que la voiture
électrique elle est comme les autres
voitures elle provoque des
embouteillages et des problèmes de
stationnement merci merci la parole à
Monsieur Frédéric marchand
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l'avenir du
tout électrique de l'automobile passe
par la région des Hauts de France
première région automobile française
notamment du fait de son bassin
industriel et du savoir-faire reconnu
des ouvriers cette ambition c'est
notamment celle de Renaud pionnier du
véhicule électrique qui investit
massivement dans cette solution confère
le modèle vedette Zoé et 32 000
exemplaires l'an dernier la marque
française se positionne également numéro
1 sur le créneau des utilitaires
électriques avec la Kangoo produite à
Maubeuge dans le département du Nord
corollaire indispensable du véhicule
électrique la batterie la région
Hauts-de-France n'est pas en reste dans
ce domaine en particulier dans le
département du Nord devenu the place to
be de la batterie électrique en quelques
années en effet après le pôle
électricité de Renault et l'implantation
du groupe chinois en vision et celle de
stelantis est total énergie à Douvrin
Dunkerque accueillera la troisième giga
usine française de production de
batterie électrique avec l'implantation
de Vercors qui permettra de faire des
Hauts de France la vallée de la batterie
segment plus qu'indispensable pour
produire sur notre sol les voitures
électriques de demain on ne peut que se
réjouir de de nouveau et la
réindustrialisation des Hauts de France
ces 3 gigas Factory se sont à terme 7500
emplois directs et 15000 indirects qui
vont être créés dans notre région c'est
un pari ambitieux qui passe par la mise
en place d'un véritable écosystème
notamment dans le domaine de la
formation en amont des futurs salariés
de ces usines celle-ci doit être
anticipée pour pouvoir alimenter en
personnel qualifier ses entreprises et
notamment en favorisant la formation des
personnels locaux dans le savoir-faire
n'est plus à démontrer à cet égard les
difficultés rencontrées par la filière
nucléaire pour trouver du personnel à
même de concrétiser ses ambitions et ses
projets doit nous servir de référence et
de garde-fou la perspective de ces
emplois est une véritable bouffée d'air
pour ce territoire longtemps meurtri
mais passe par un énorme défi dans le
domaine de la formation la réussite du
tout électrique dans notre pays passe
par une mobilisation qui doit embarquer
tous les acteurs de la formation et
notamment l'éducation nationale alors
madame la ministre quels sont les
orientations retenues par le
gouvernement pour réussir ce défi de la
formation garant essentiel de la
réussite du tout électrique
merci même la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur marchand vous l'avez mentionné
avec clarté oui le Nord Est au cœur du
déploiement de l'écosystème en faveur
des de l'automobile électrique le
constructeur Renault s'engage fortement
dans l'électricité de saga avec
notamment la constitution du pôle
électrique City dans le nord de la
France autour des villes de Douai de
Maubeuge de ruythe avec un objet actif
d'un million de véhicules produits par
an en 2031 en parallèle trois
entreprises ont des projets de
construction de méga usine de batterie
de véhicules électriques dans les hauts
de France a cessé à Douvrin Vercors à
Dunkerque et nvidjan à Douai ces usines
devraient créer au moins 6500 emplois
directs à l'horizon 2030 vous mentionnez
monsieur le sénateur 7500 emplois c'est
à peu près les tirages que nous avons et
comme vous nous réjouissons des
perspectives de constitution en France
une filière complète des véhicules de
demain mais aussi surtout de la création
d'emplois que cela va susciter vous
évoqué et je vous en remercie la
question fort légitime de la formation
il nous faut apporter une réponse rapide
et former à ces métiers dont certains
sont quand même non pas des métiers de
l'automobile classique mais les métiers
de l'automobile de demain vous le savez
à travers France 2030 nous mobilisons
pas mal de moyens et je vous rappelle
que 2,5 milliards d'euros sont mobilisés
sur la formation et les compétences rien
qu'à travers pardonner moi France 2030
je ne parle même pas des efforts
réalisés pendant le précédent
quinquennat à titre d'exemple ça va
permettre et ça a permis surtout à
l'état de soutenir le projet remède que
vous connaissez à hauteur de 14 millions
d'euros ce projet lauréat de l'appel a
manifestation France 2030 accélère la
structuration nouvelle formation autour
de technologie automobile d'avenir
l'école de la batterie portée par
Vercors à Grenoble à rechut 14 millions
d'aides dans le cadre de cet appel à
manifestation d'intérêt deux autres
projets sont également lauréats dans les
hautes France pour répondre aux besoins
à court terme en matière de formation
den vision nous travaillons aussi et je
vais vite au niveau des comités
stratégiques de filière du conseil de
l'industrie pour aussi identifier plus
les compétences dont nous aurons besoin
je ne serai pas plus longue la
présidente m'en voudrait je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à Madame Martine filleul
si madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le les
hasards de la vie font que ma question
est assez proche de celle de Monsieur
marchand vous allez donc pouvoir
approfondir votre votre réponse madame
la ministre des carbonés au plus vite le
parc automobile afin de respecter nos
engagements environnementaux est un
impératif reste à savoir comment nous
allons atteindre cet objectif en aucun
cas nous ne pouvons mettre sous le tapis
les implications sociales et économiques
pour les personnes les plus vulnérables
concernées par cette mieux
incontournable je pensais évidemment à
nos compatriotes au fin de mois
difficiles pour qu'il achat d'un nouveau
véhicule électrique est hors de portée
malgré les aides des amis en place mais
je pense aussi comme sénatrice du Nord à
mon territoire qui vous le savez à
particulièrement souffert d'une
désindustrialisation massive depuis la
fin des 30 gorilleuses constructeur ou
équipementiers ce ne sont pas moins de
50 000 employés qui travaillent
aujourd'hui dans le secteur automobile
le président de la République a prévu la
production de 2 millions de véhicules
électriques et hybrides en France à
l'horizon 2030 et 3 projets de
gigafactory à Doué Dunkerque et Maubeuge
ont été annoncés mais un chiffre
m'interpelle en raison d'un nombre de
pièces inférieures là où il fallait 5
ouvriers pour produire un véhicule
thermique pardon seuls trois suffisent
désormais pour un véhicule électrique
vous évoquez seulement 7000 6500 emplois
pouvez nous nous assurer qu'au 1er
janvier 2035 à la fois que la filière
automobile française sera prête et que
nos territoires industrialisés ne seront
pas une nouvelle fois sinistrée que
prévoit l'État pour prévenir la
disparition de certains postes dans
l'industrie automobile et assurer la
conversion des salariés et avec
madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente je réponds à
l'invitation de la sénatrice filleul et
si vous motorisez je vais poursuivre ce
que je n'ai pas pu dire juste avant
au-delà de tous les projets que le
Territoire du Nord a réussi à remporter
puisque quand même rendons hommage au
territoire c'est le territoire qui gagne
et qui est lauréat de ses nombreuses
appels à manifestation d'intérêt et je
voulais aussi ajouter que nous sommes en
train de travailler j'allais trop vite
au niveau des comités de stratégiques de
filière au Conseil national de
l'industrie pour identifier justement
les compétences dont nous allons avoir
besoin dans le cadre de ces nouvelles
productions et donc de ces nouveaux
métiers et je veux aussi ajouter un mot
sur le fait que Bruno Le Maire vous le
savez présentera d'ici quelques mois un
projet de loi très important de
réindustrialisation verte je tiens à
vous dire qu'il l'abordera très
clairement avec un accentier du projet
de loi madame la sénatrice la question
majeure de la formation des compétences
et des talents on a donc missionné deux
pilotes pour le chantier spécifique de
la formation au sein du projet de loi
réindustrialisation verte madame la
députée Astrid panochon Bouvet que vous
c'est sûrement et monsieur Moussa Camara
président fondateur des déterminés il
travaille ensemble depuis quelques
semaines et son disponibles si vous
souhaitez échanger et on peut organiser
la mise en relation en organisant
justement des échanges précis pour faire
remonter des propositions concrètes en
matière de formation et notamment pour
les personnes les plus éloignées ou les
plus fragiles en matière d'employabilité
celle que vous mentionnez madame la
sénatrice ces propositions que vont
porter c'est de personnalités en
vocation justement à venir nourrir le
véhicule législatif qui arrivera dans
quelques mois sur le sujet de la
formation professionnelle de
l'enseignement aussi professionnel mais
aussi supérieur et c'est l'ensemble du
gouvernement au-delà de Bruno Le Maire
mais avec aussi le ministre de
l'Éducation le ministre du Travail qui
va s'appeler au sein d'un axe entier du
projet de réindustrialisation verte à
essayer de renforcer au maximum
l'employabilité et la qualité des
formations en faveur de de l'industrie
de l'automobile électrique c'est une
invitation là aussi peut-être ce que
vous voulez nourrissiez en tout cas on
en a besoin je vous remercie madame la
sénatrice merci la parole est à monsieur
le Président Pierre Laurent
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre l'objectif
2035 a été entériné son véritable étude
d'impact et sans planification globale
sur le mode décidons l'un de
l'intendance suivra dès lors nous
avançons sans stratégie clair en
laissant la main aux industriels pour
définir nos objectifs de production et
en courant le risque de soit de ne pas
réussir soit de le faire dans les pires
conditions avec inégalité manque de
souveraineté à la clé parmi les
problèmes malmétrisés je souhaite vous
interroger sur les perspectives
d'approvisionnement en matière première
critique composant les batteries au
titre desquelles figure la volonté
déclarée du retour des mines en Europe
et la constitution de stocks stratégique
le principal projet de lithium européen
à Jada en Serbie
que devait exploiter le tristement
célèbre Riotinto a été pour leur
abandonnée par ce pays pour des raisons
écologiques quant à l'Union européenne
elle s'apprête à assouplir dans
l'urgence les règles environnementales
pour faciliter l'implantation des mines
je souhaite donc vous poser plusieurs
questions à ce propos disposeront nous
et quand d'une véritable étude d'impact
sur les besoins en matériaux critique
pour satisfaire la demande européenne en
véhicule électrique
comptez-vous renforcer le soutien public
dans le cadre du Plan France 2030 dont
132 millions d'euros ont été décaissés
en un an dans le volet matière première
en garantissant que cet argent servent
en France à des projets d'exploration et
de raffinage conformes à nos ambitions
industrielles et écologiques enfin
quelle nouvelle règle de commerce
international la France entend elle
promouvoir contrôler logique de
rentabilité prédatrice de quelques
grands groupes mondiaux qui dominent
aujourd'hui pour garantir et sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des matières
premières critiques nécessaires aux
transitions écologique dans ce cadre
êtes-vous prête avec le gouvernement à
agir pour sortir d'une logique de
souveraineté égoïste fondée sur la
guerre concurrentielle entre État et
entre filières au profit d'un marché
mondial basé sur une logique de bien
commun
psychologiquement responsable et soumis
à côté équitablement réparti merci
madame la ministre
je rappelle c'est 2 minutes c'est pas
plus après si vous souhaitez avoir
davantage vous faites un peu moins de 2
minutes et vous aurez la réplique voilà
c'est on fait on veut faire un débat
interactif là c'est pas le cas quand
vous faites comme ça merci même la
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Sénateur Laurent sur la
filière automobile en France vous et sur
le surtout le
l'objectif européen que nous sommes
fixés votre jugement et le vôtre mais il
est dur je ne crois pas que nous
puissions dire que nous n'avons aucune
stratégie claire en la matière bien sûr
le la bascule est majeur elle peut être
anxiogène mais je pense que nous avons
une stratégie et d'ailleurs il est prévu
des une étape avant 2035 vous le savez
la stratégie elle est assez claire pour
donner de la visibilité aux industriels
et aux consommateurs je vous l'ai dit
produire 2 millions de véhicules
électriques par an en 2030 une
mobilisation massive des moyens de
l'État pas moins de 5 milliards d'euros
dans le cadre du Plan France 2030 et ce
hors du sujet compétences formation dont
nous venons de parler qui sera lui-même
abondé par ailleurs et le soutien est
massif que du côté de l'État pour
justement accompagner cette mutation
vous me questionnez j'ai à coeur d'y
répondre sur le sujet majeur des des
matériaux critiques
je veux rappeler que d'abord il est
possible de recycler les métaux des
batteries et je pense que vous le savez
jusqu'à 99% que ce soit le lithium le
nickel ou encore le cobalt et en plus ça
conduirait si on parvenait à les
recycler plus par construction en
extraire moins du sol ce qui serait
moins délétère pour notre planète des
projets d'ailleurs émergent beaucoup en
France pour bâtir difficile de recyclage
des batteries de véhicules électriques
nous disposons par ailleurs en France de
gisements de matériaux constitutifs des
batteries le groupe par exemple le
groupe Imerys qui a annoncé en octobre
2022 lancement d'un important projet
d'exploitation de lithium dans l'Allier
qui représente une capacité d'équipement
de 700000 véhicules en batterie lithium
yon par an j'ajoute qu'il y a à peu près
un mois un délégué interministériel au
métaux critique a été nommé Benjamin
galietzo qui est à votre disposition et
à la disposition de l'ensemble des
parlementaires pour aborder le sujet que
vous avez pointé sur les matériaux
critiques je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Monsieur Patrick Chauvet
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le 20
octobre dernier durant la séance de
questions d'actualité j'alertais le
ministre délégué chargé des transports
au sujet des dangers d'une interdiction
pure et dure des véhicules thermiques à
partir de 2035 je ne suis pas certain
qu'elle soit souhaitable au regard des
investissements colossaux consentis par
nos constructeurs pour améliorer les
performances écologiques des moteurs
thermiques de plus la montée en charge
du véhicule électrique interroge
également quant à la pérennité de notre
souveraineté industrielle en effet nous
sommes aujourd'hui dépendants de
certaines filières d'approvisionnement
notamment concernant l'importation de
terres rares c'est précieux métaux
décisifs pour le fonctionnement des
batteries en cas de conflit géopolitique
d'ampleur nous serions ainsi vulnérables
quant à notre capacité à continuer de
faire fonctionner notre filière
automobile en dépit de cela il est
impératif que nous soyons compétitifs
sur le marché du véhicule électrique à
l'horizon 2035
mes chers collègues nous sommes tous
conscients je crois que la concurrence
internationale ne nous fera aucun cadeau
la Chine a ainsi fait très tôt le pari
de l'électrique contrôlant 56% de la
production mondiale des batteries Pékin
s'est doté d'une industrie de
l'automobile électrique
ultra compétitive où les véhicules
chinois coûtent jusqu'à 30% moins cher
que ceux de leurs concurrents européens
de leur côté les États-Unis soutiennent
massivement leur constructeur et leur
industrie verte avec 370 milliards de
dollars avec nos partenaires européens
et nos constructeurs automobiles nous
devons donc dessiner les contours d'un
nouveau pacte industriel pour relever le
défi du véhicule électrique à ce titre
je salue les annonces de la présidente
wanter Leyens en date du 17 et du 31
janvier dernier de la mise en place d'un
plan industriel européen pour la
compétitivité de nos industries vertes
pourtant les récentes prises de position
de certains dirigeants des États membres
semblent mettre en péril cette négative
je terminerai juste par ma question
faut voir par groupe politique mais ça a
été décidé avec vos présidents donc on
va pas changer la règle aujourd'hui
madame la ministre et vous qui avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente exercice
périlleux je vais essayer de répondre à
une question que j'imagine et je vous
demande de la bienveillance il se peut
que je réponde à côté mais je veux quand
même vous dire un mot sur le fait que
évidemment c'est un mouvement majeur
mais je pense que nous en sommes je
pense le gouvernement pense que nous en
sommes capables et l'Europe se met en
position et je voulais peut-être faire
un
focus sur ce que nous faisons en France
justement et les efforts considérables
que nous mettons en place pour aussi
accompagner bien sûr les acteurs mais
aussi tous les sous-traitants qui sont
au cœur de la filière puisqu'on se l'ai
dit et le Président babary il a dit dans
sa discussion générale l'enjeu n'est pas
que la question des batteries
électriques l'enjeu est bien plus
largement la question de la chaîne de
valeur d'abord rappeler que comme dans
chaque mutation industrielle majeure
bien sûr certaines certains savoir-faire
et certains emplois disparaîtront mais
il y a aussi de nombreuses innovations
et de nombreuses opportunités indus qui
sont en train de se créer dans notre
pays qui sont autant de secteur de
croissance et création d'emplois ensuite
dire que les sous-traitants de la
filière automobile traditionnelle sont
en train de se diversifier bien sûr
l'empreinte carbone des véhicules
thermiques que vous mentionnez monsieur
le député diminue mais pour pardon
excusez-moi autant pour moi voilà je
vais perdre du temps non non les
sous-traitants de la filière automobile
se diversifient soit vers des segments
de la filière non-exposée au
motorisation thermique soit vers de
nouveaux secteurs je le disais hors
automobile pour accompagner ces
changements l'état accompagne les
sous-traitants directement en leur
dédiant pas moins de 1/5 des 5 milliards
du soutien de la filière automobile
c'est un milliard d'euros pour nos
sous-traitants qui va permettre de
soutenir leur croissance qui va
permettre de faciliter la transition des
sous-traitants historiques d'accompagner
aussi la reconversion des salariés et
des sites et des territoires impactés et
vous dire aussi que Bercy à mandaté
aussi le Conseil Général de l'économie
mais aussi l'inspection générale des
finances pour évaluer les conséquences
sur le tissu
industriels ensuite la crise de la covid
19 a mis en péril les circuits
d'acheminement des matériaux nécessaires
à la fabrication des batteries des
gisements ont été découverts en Europe
mais il faudra des années avant de
pouvoir en tirer les fruits quand on
déploiement des bandes de chargement
sera-t-il en mesure de suivre le rythme
de la progression attendue des voitures
électriques et donc peu probable que
l'objectif de toute électrique en 2035
soit atteignable d'autant que les
fabricants torse est déjà atteint leur
première objectif de réduction de gaz à
effet de serre et serait peut-être tenté
de mettre la douce sans mauvais
jeu de mots sur la production électrique
pour écouler leur stock de véhicules
thermiques partant de là n'est-il pas
opportablement ministre de miser aussi
sur l'hybride en relançant par exemple
le dispositif fiscal qui était supprimé
et qu'en est-il de l'hydrogène ne
faut-il pas par ailleurs accompagner la
transition énergétique et la conversion
de notre parc actuel de véhicules
thermiques afin qu'il soit moins
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre enfin
pouvez-vous rassurer l'inquiétude
légitime de nos industriels de
l'automobile au regard du plan d'aide
américain massif qui résoudait le
fragilisé et par exemple je vous offre
mes 15 secondes
quelle générosité oserais-je dire au
sénateurs
me pose pas moins de 6 questions quel
challenge donc je vais oublier
obligatoirement monsieur le sénateur
être obligé de concentrer un peu ma
réponse et je m'en excuse ça n'empêche
pas des réponses par ailleurs aux autres
points que vous abordez 1 aide à
l'acquisition de véhicules électriques
évidemment vous l'avez dit elles sont
encore plus chères parfois même bien
plus cher que les véhicules thermiques
rappelez quand même que plus d'un
milliard d'euros de crédit budgétaires
ont été consommés au titre du bonus
écologique en 2022 plus de 325 000
dossiers traités rappelés que le depuis
le 1er janvier 2023 comme vous le savez
monsieur le sénateur le bonus écologique
voit son montant maximal diminué de 6000
à 5000 euros pour les particuliers mais
il pourra être majoré de 2000 euros
comme vous le savez vous savez pour près
de la moitié des ménages rappelez aussi
que le leasing social à 100 euros par
mois sera aussi proposé courant 2024
comme nous nous y étions engagés au
ménage les plus modestes
rappeler enfin que s'agissant de la
prime à la conversion elle exclut les
ménages les plus aisés elle peut aller
elle aussi jusqu'à 6000 euros en
fonction des revenus de l'acquéreur par
ailleurs c'est important de le
mentionner le rétrofit on ne le sait pas
assez et éligible à une aide allant
jusqu'à 6000 euros en 2022 les
constructeurs français sont concernés
par près de 50% des bonus octroyés
nous devons néanmoins réfléchir à des
critères je ne doute pas que vous serez
force de proposition au Sénat dans le
cas du projet de loi réindustrialisation
verte qui sera le vecteur de cette
évolution je voudrais aussi quand même
rapidement vous répondre sur les bornes
au 31 décembre 2022 la France dispose de
plus de 82000 points de recharge plus
53% sur les 12 derniers mois l'objectif
des 100 000 bornes
devrait être atteintes être atteint
pardonnez-moi au deuxième trimestre 2023
bien sûr on a pris un peu de retard je
ne le nie pas le contexte a été aussi
difficile ça nous place quand même la
France au troisième rang des pays les
mieux équipés dans l'Union européenne
donc certes derrière nos voisins du nord
les Pays-Bas et les Allemands mais nous
ne sommes pas en reste et nous allons
continuer à en installer je vous
remercie merci
non parce que moi je vais vous
réexpliquer parce que je pense que les
gens comprennent pas bien si vous prenez
même ne serait-ce que 5 secondes vous
rendez aussi une minute à madame la
ministre qui peut passer un peu plus de
temps pour vous répondre derrière vous
avez encore une minute donc voilà c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis précise sur les
temps de parole vous voyez que vous
voulez prendre la parole je reprends mes
15 secondes et je dis je vous remercie
madame Miss de vos réponses comme ça je
rends une minute supplémentaire madame
la ministre comme ça elle pourra
répondre doucement plus doucement
même la ministre vous aviez quelque
chose à ajouter
et ça sur les bornes
merci madame la Présidente grunis et
pardonné ce débit parfois accéléré
mais l'exercice n'est pas évident je
voulais juste terminer sur les
oui mais c'est vous savez que j'aime le
Sénat monsieur le sénateur
juste vous dire que sur les recharges
plus de 90% des recharges c'est on le
sait pas non plus elle s'effectue à
domicile et 20% des Français vivent en
résidentiel collective disposant d'un
parking et vous dire que dans ce
contexte l'État soutient beaucoup les
dispositifs facilitant l'acquisition
l'installation de matériel de recharge
dans les logements collectifs en plus du
crédit d'impôt de la prime à devenir et
d'un taux de TVA réduit pour les bornes
achetés par les particuliers plusieurs
outils de financement sont mises à
disposition des bailleurs et des
particuliers par la banque des
territoires ces outils doivent nous
permettre d'atteindre un objectif de
16000 copropriétés privées accompagnés
d'ici 2024 pour plus de 125 000 points
de recharge merci madame la Présidente
merci c'est bon monsieur corbizet très
bien sinon vous aviez encore une minute
la parole est à Madame Françoise Dumont
madame la présidente madame la ministre
l'Union européenne a donc acté la fin de
la vente des véhicules neufs à moteur
thermique à compter 2035 les ZFE fleurit
fleurissent pardon dans les métropoles
européennes sur le papier ce changement
complet de façon de penser la mobilité
pour ressembler intéressant du point de
vue de la réduction des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais le diable se cache
dans les détails premièrement comment
rajouter le raccordement d'un parc
automobile sur notre production
vacillante pour quel prix de
rechargement avec l'augmentation des
coûts de l'énergie sans même parler du
retard pris par le déploiement des
bornes de rechargement vous venez de
l'évoquer enfin les entreprises
automobiles françaises et européennes ne
sont pas en capacité à ce jour de
répondre à l'immense vague de demande
qui va se mettre en place dans toutes
les prochaines dans les toutes
prochaines années ce sont donc les
entreprises chinoises qui bénéficieront
de cette nouvelle manne financière puis
en cette période de forte inflation
comment des familles devant changer un
de véhicules pourront-elles le faire en
effet même avec des aides ciblées de
l'État le reste à charge pour les
particuliers mais aussi pour les
artisans sera très conséquent de plus
s'agissant d'une technologie assez
récente la question du recours à l'achat
d'occasion ne pourra pas forcément être
une option pour l'ensemble des acheteurs
enfin il y a la question de la gestion
des incendies de véhicules électriques
et qui n'est pas des moindres qui
imposent beaucoup de contraintes pour
nos services de secours en effet
lorsqu'un véhicule lorsqu’un feu de
véhicule électrique se produit les
sapeurs-pompiers doivent refroidir le
véhicule brûlé voir donc l'immergé dans
de l'eau pendant des dizaines d'heures
d'affilée pour éliminer le risque d'un
nouveau départ de feu depuis une
batterie en surchauffe or noz 10 ne sont
pas tous équipés pour répondre à un
risque qui ne fait que s'accroître avec
l'électrification du parc roulant aussi
madame la ministre regarde tous ces
points comment le gouvernement
envisage-t-il d'accompagner cette
révolution de la mobilité sans
abandonner les particuliers les artisans
voire même
la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice du monde
nous disons pas que ce sera facile nous
disons que là où il y a une volonté il y
a un chemin on peut regarder toutes les
complications il y en a beaucoup mais je
peux pas laisser dire sur les recharges
par exemple
bien sûr on a pris un peu de retard je
ne nie pas le fait que ça devait être
ces chiffres en fin d'année 2022 il
s'est passé pas mal de choses vous le
savez comme moi mais les chiffres sont
quand même assez encourageants plus 53%
en 12 mois la France 3e pays dont
l'Union européenne en matière
d'installation de recharge pour les
véhicules électriques voilà je vous
passerai le pessimisme du meurt et
l'optimisme de volonté mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on y croit et même s'il y
a pas mal de difficultés les aidefe en
font partie je pense que on s'en sort
plutôt pas mal et les chiffres en
matière d'installation de bornes le
démontre sur les ZF
je veux rappeler deux choses d'abord le
gouvernement a mis en place des aides
substantielles vous le savez pour aider
les professionnels à remplacer leur
véhicule thermique par un véhicule
électrique aide quand je dis
substantielle qui peut aller jusqu'à
13000 euros de subventions par l'achat
de
véhicule utilitaire électrique selon
leur masse en incluant la prime à la
conversion c'est important notamment
pour les artisans et les indépendants
sur lesquels je suis évidemment
particulièrement vigilante ensuite même
si l'objectif est clair je comprends
très bien mais alors très bien qu'il
puisse soulever certaines interrogations
voire plus il est important que ces
aideux soient mises en place de manière
concertée avec toutes les parties
prenantes c'est le cas dans un certain
nombre de métropoles je ne saurai
qu'appeler la concertation dans toutes
et notamment dans celle dont j'ai
l'honneur d'être élu le gouvernement a
ainsi mis en place un point d'entrée
unique par ailleurs avec la nomination
d'un coordinateur interministériel aux
ZFE monsieur Manini qui est à la
disposition des parlementaires qui
souhaiteraient le soumettre le soumettre
pas du tout le rencontrer mais pas le
soumettre du tout vous enfin ou pourquoi
pas enfin ça c'est à vous de voir madame
la sénatrice non en revanche blague à
part vous mentionnez en tant que
sénatrice du Var le point important des
incendies sur lequel je vous le dis je
n'ai pas de réponse je comprends votre
sensibilité et donc je suggère qu'on y
réponde je n'ai pas la réponse à cette
heure mais on vous doit une réponse
merci merci la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre-Jean verzelen
la Présidente je vais vous permettre de
reparler des des bornes électriques sur
le débat qui nous est posé vous avez
donné les chiffres aujourd'hui il y a 80
000 bornes qui sont installés un retard
qui a été pris et à la fin de la
décennie on devrait en théorie atteindre
quasiment 500 000 bornes de posées
sachant qu'on se bat sur un calcul qui
fait qu'il faudrait une borne électrique
à peu près pour 10 véhicules
il y a les nouvelles qui vont être
installées il y a celles qu'il faudra
changer puisque la technique la
technologie évolue pour permettre de
recharger les véhicules plus vite alors
il y a le sujet du nombre et après il y
a le sujet du lieu où est-ce que nous
allons mettre ces bornes et pour un
certain nombre de villes et de centre
bourg ça va être une révolution en
termes d'organisation de de la commune
vous disiez tout à l'heure 80% des
recharges se font à domicile c'est ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que tout le monde n'a pas un
garage tout le monde n'a pas un terrain
il y a ceux qui sont dans l'habitat
collectif je ne doute pas que dans des
parkings on va réussir à s'organiser etc
mais il y a tout le reste qu'on connaît
dans les villes et j'allais dire même
plutôt dans les centres bourg ces rues
où vous avez un habitat qui est contigu
où les gens n'ont pas de garage n'ont
pas de parking n'ont pas de place qui
sont définies devant chez eux et là les
choses vont être beaucoup comment
beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué donc je
voulais savoir où en était l'état des
réflexions pour
un endroit plus complexe pour installer
les bornes savoir où en était l'état des
discussions avec les maires mais les
associations qui sont censés les
représenter et si le sujet du coût était
abordé puisque cette nouvelle
organisation dans les communes et dans
les villes va coûter aux uns aux autres
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent merci de
votre réponse merci madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente sur les
infrastructures de recharge de véhicules
électriques effectivement la diversité
de du territoire des centres bourdes
Noville de nos villages rend le sujet
important je veux quand même rappeler
d'abord vous l'avez dit qu'une partie
significative du territoire et est ainsi
couverte puisque en milieu rural dans
les départements ruraux vous avez pas
mal d'habitats individuels je ne
mentionne pas les centres bourses que
vous avez mentionnés et avec là une
possibilité de se recharger sur une
place privée loin de moi l'idée que tout
le monde aurait un garage un jardin et
une maison donc dans ce contexte l'état
soutien de nombreux dispositifs pour
faciliter l'acquisition l'installation
de matériel de recharge dans les
logements et je pense ici au crédit
d'impôt mais aussi au taux de TVA réduit
à 5,5 pour les bornes achetées pour des
particuliers
pour ceux qui est de nos collectivités
territoriales plusieurs mesures sont
mises en place pour soutenir ce
déploiement en dehors des neurbains à
hauteur de collectivités territoriales
l'appel à progestation de recharge haute
puissance qui est dotée à 7h d'une
enveloppe de 300 millions d'euros dans
le cadre de France 2030 prévoit une
intensité des aides plus importante pour
le déploiement de station situé en
dehors des dix principales métropoles
urbaines cette enveloppe de 300 millions
et dans l'appel à projet station de
recharge haute puissance la banque des
territoires et l'interlocuteur qui
aujourd'hui propose des dispositifs
d'accompagnement de financement aux
collectivités locales au délégataire de
collectivité au bailleur mais aussi aux
propriétaires en copropriété l'État est
aux côtés des acteurs locaux plus 60%
des bornes aujourd'hui ouverte au public
ont été installés sous la maîtrise
d'ouvrage de collectivités ou
d’établissement public et la réalisation
de schémas directeur dédié doit
permettre aux acteurs locaux
d'être légitimement moteur dans le
déploiement de ces infrastructures avec
un financement bien sûr facilité auprès
de la banque des territoires je vous
remercie Monsieur verzelaine Merci la
parole est à Monsieur Hervé gilet
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la décarbonation des transports
routiers la dépollution des milieux
urbains nécessite une adaptation
volontariste des flottes de véhicule
professionnel et particuliers la fin de
la production et de la vente des moteurs
thermiques en 2035 interroge la capacité
des constructeurs à réorienter leur
gamme notamment au niveau européen à la
recherche de plus-value plus conséquente
ces derniers produisent des véhicules
électriques de plus en plus lourd de
plus en plus cher et de plus en plus
consommateurs d'énergie les véhicules
d'entrée de gamme et donc plus
facilement accessibles pour les ménages
modestes sont de moins en moins nombreux
au bénéfice d'une concurrence
internationale et notamment chinoise
plus adapté et plus attractive quel
soutient la filière française
pourriez-vous envisager pour faciliter
la production de véhicules d'entrée de
gamme avez-vous des exemples concrets
ainsi vouloir réserver des primes d'aide
à l'achat au constructeur européen à
l'instar des États-Unis reviendrait à
empêcher les ménages modestes de
s'équiper afin de ne pas être pénalisé
par l’alourdissement des fiscalités sur
les énergies carbonées et la mise en
place des et des feux en d'autres termes
toujours plus de discrimination
envisagez-vous ce ciblage des primes
vers les constructeurs européens et donc
une forme de protectionnisme pour
accompagner les ménages les plus
modestes où en êtes-vous du lancement
d'un dispositif de leasing social
facilitant l'accès aux véhicules propres
notamment pour faciliter l'accès aux et
des feux par ailleurs de nombreuses
études confirment l'intérêt de
développer une filière de production de
véhicules intermédiaires donc léger pour
les mobilités du quotidien nécessitant
moins de puissance et donc plus
accessible pour l'ensemble des
utilisateurs quel intérêt portez-vous
sur ces nouveaux concepts le
gouvernement serait-il favorable à
soutenir et développer ses filières à
l'échelle nationale je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur gilet si vous m'autorisez je
commence déjà par répondre sur le
leasing social oui
en 204
je
c'est loin mais ça suppose aussi qu'on
s'en parle enfin du moins que vous en
parliez j'imagine et que vous soyez aux
côtés du ministre Beaune en charge des
transports
moi c'est l'information dont je dispose
et ça suppose aussi qui est sûrement une
concertation en amont ce qui me semble
de bonalois pour nourrir le projet mais
il sera mis en oeuvre en 2024 ça veut
pas dire qu'on puisse pas y travailler
là au deuxième semestre par exemple pour
ce qui est ensuite du sujet absolument
majeur de la concurrence internationale
oui vous avez raison vous avez évoqué
l'inflation réduction acte américain
Lyra après voit un crédit d'impôt
pouvant atteindre 7500 dollars pour les
particuliers achetant un véhicule
électrique assemblé en Amérique du Nord
et dont les batteries satisfont une
exigence additionnelle de contenu local
cette mesure c'est une aide publique
manifestement incompatible avec le droit
de l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
qui comme vous le savez aussi bien que
moi interdit de manière générale à ces
membres de favoriser leurs produits
nationaux
par rapport aux produits importés nous
n'avons pas du tout l'intention de
rester inactif face à l'IRA Bruno Le
Maire est en train de travailler en ce
moment même avec le ministre de
l'Industrie Roland Lescure à la
préparation du projet de loi
réindustrialisation verte dont je ne
doute pas pour avoir le plaisir de
travailler avec lui depuis maintenant 3
ans qui l'associera en amont tout à la
fois les députés mais aussi évidemment
les sénateurs nous travaillons très
sérieusement à des critères notamment
environnementaux qui permettrait de
réserver nos aides à l'acquisition au
seul véhicule fabriqués en France ou en
Europe c'est donc une invitation qui
sera d'ailleurs conclue et conclusive
dans les prochaines semaines à
travailler si vous le souhaitez et être
force de nos propositions sur ce sujet
dans le cadre du projet Loire et
industrialisation verte les critères
sont en cours merci merci Monsieur gilet
vous avez 16 secondes
merci madame la Présidente mais vous
voyez bien l'objet pour que les gens qui
ont des faibles moyens puissent acquérir
des véhicules encore faut-il que ces
véhicules ne soient pas trop onéreux or
à l'heure actuelle on a une dérive donc
comment fait-on pour que les producteurs
français produisent des véhicules qui
sont pas chers
collègues en octobre dernier conseil et
Parlement européen ont entériné la fin
de la vente des véhicules à moteur
thermique dans l'Union européenne pour
2035 au profit de véhicules 100%
électrique ce choix politique suscite
des interrogations légitimes à titre
d'exemple la massification de la voiture
électrique entraînera une hausse
significative de la consommation
d'électricité en France or notre
consommation électrique à s'acné pendant
20 ans en dépit des aléas
conjoncturelles par conséquent je me
demande si notre système de production
électrique peut vraiment monter en
puissance nous avons tous encore en tête
les exhortations du gouvernement à la
sobriété pour éviter coupure et
délestages cet hiver cela ne rassure
donc pas sur cette question alors certes
le gouvernement
semble avoir pris la mesure de l'urgence
avec deux projets de loi visant à
accélérer l'un la production de NR et
l'autre les procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires mais les premiers maitrons
sans doute plusieurs années avant de
fonctionner quant au second elles ne
seront jamais prêtes à avant 2030 par
conséquent je voudrais savoir comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il résoudre
l'équation d'une consommation électrique
augmentant plus rapidement que la
production d'électricité ne serait-il
pas pertinent d'envisager d'autres
solutions comme le biogaz qui présente
un intérêt certain pour décarboner la
mobilité des poids lourds je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Sempé merci pour votre
question vous interrogez gouvernement
sur le risque de notre système
énergétique d'un accroissement de la
consommation d'électricité en France
d'abord une étude que j'imagine vous
connaissez publier en 2019 par RTE a
démontré l'impact de la mobilité
électrique sur la consommation
électrique française
j'ai perdu 4 secondes pardon
pardonnez-moi madame la Présidente
cette étude désolé confirme que le
système électrique français peut
absorber le développement du véhicule
électrique avec pilotage limité de la
recharge la consommation totale
d'électricité des transports individuels
et collectifs
pèserait au plus un dixième de la
consommation d'électricité totale en
France à échéance 2035 c'est moins que
la consommation du chauffage résidentiel
c'est moins que l'augmentation de la
consommation électrique de la France
entre 2000 et 2010
je voudrais pas que le sénateur Babarit
tout ceci on va pas y arriver
désolé
je suis désolé
[Musique]
mon souffle ma voix et je suis là pour
répondre aux questions pardonnez-moi
je vous remercie
donc c'est moins de la consommation du
chauffage résidentiel c'est moins que
l'augmentation de la consommation
électrique de la France entre 2000 et
2010 par ailleurs la consommation
énergétique additionnelle qui est
nécessaire à l'électrification du parc
pourrait en grande partie être justement
compensé par les gains d'efficacité
énergétique dans les autres secteurs
comme le logement par exemple puisque
nous menons en parallèle comme vous le
savez une vaste politique de rénovation
énergétique par ailleurs le pilotage dit
intelligent de la recharge peut
permettre de lisser les besoins de
consommation pour éviter les pointes de
consommation qui sont gourmandes en
énergie et qui entretiennent le besoin
d'importation ou la nécessaire
production d'énergie fossiles le
développement d'outils intelligents de
recharge sera une des clés de la
soutenabilité des véhicules électriques
et pourrait apporter un élément de
réponse aux besoins grandissant de
flexibilité du réseau électrique
vous questionnez enfin madame la
sénatrice la possibilité d'utiliser le
biogaz pour la mobilité le bilan carbone
du biogaz peut certes concurrencer celui
des véhicules électriques mais l'analyse
du cycle de vie assez limite elle ignore
la disponibilité concrète et les
colliers aux technologies or le biogaz a
une disponibilité actuelle et future
limitée
et sa charge et sa large distribution
nécessiterait des investissements forts
ces deux contraintes ne permettent pas à
cette heure d'en faire une alternative à
l'électrique pour décarboner les
voitures ou les utilitaires légers c'est
donc pourquoi nous recommandons de
réserver les ressources limitées de
biogaz pour des secteurs qui sont déjà
dépendants du gaz plutôt que de créer
une demande supplémentaire dans un
secteur du transport où il existe des
technologies plus adaptées plus matures
pardonnez-moi
oui simplement madame la ministre je
crois que c'est de l'utopique de penser
que la consommation électrique
n'augmentera pas et que vous tablez
essentiellement sur les économies qui
seront faites et deuxièmement le biogaz
je ne comprends pas cette réticence du
gouvernement de ne pas utiliser le
biogaz qui est une ressource présente
sur les territoires je vous remercie
merci
même la ministre pas de réponse pour
l'instant
je vais je vais suspendre ensuite une
minute pour vous laisser voilà reprendre
mon souffle
je crois pas que RTE soit
connu pour sa propension à l'utopie mais
je comprends vos doutes encore une fois
la bascule elle est majeure et le doute
et salutaire mais je me permets de vous
renvoyer à cette étude pour ce qui est
du biogaz objection retenue du moins
entendu et je suggère peut-être qu'avec
la ministre de l'Énergie auquel je peux
tout à fait faire un message vous en
discutiez plus profondément je ne suis
peut-être pas aussi spécialiste que vous
madame la sédatrice je vous remercie
merci
d'accord donc je suspends une minute la
séance est suspendue
la séance est reprise je donne la parole
à Monsieur Philippe Tabarro
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la France nourrit comme
d'autres pays des objectifs de
développement des véhicules électriques
plus qu'une promesse c'est un
incontestable défi pour la filière
automobile mais qui cache mal
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
difficultés première difficulté ça a été
dit dans le contexte délicat d'abandon
manifeste du nucléaire la puissance
électrique en France est de plus en plus
questionné il y a aujourd'hui en France
environ 44 millions de voitures
concernées après 2035 pour
l'électrification le remplacement massif
de véhicules thermiques par des
véhicules électriques va démultiplier la
consommation électrique qui va accroître
d'environ 25 pour 100 par rapport à
aujourd'hui mais pas seulement seconde
difficulté nous avons aussi à faire face
à des très fortes tensions sur certains
matériaux je pense notamment
semi-conducteur nous avons enfin face à
la radicalité à la généralisation des
ZFE un problème de souveraineté
industrielle alors qu'il faut
accompagner les Français massivement
vers la transition électrique les aides
actuelles pour ceux qui peuvent se
permettre d'acquérir une voiture
électrique bénéficie très
majoritairement à la chatte voiturette
alors que notre pays clament l'urgence
de s'en doter la France est même
l'Europe sont littéralement à la
remorque de la Chine de sa puissance de
frappe actuelle sur la construction de
voitures électriques et de batterie
madame la ministre force est de
constater que ce sujet vire au
casse-tête retard sur les bords retard
sur le matériel coup prohibiti forme
prenne carbone de la production coût de
l'énergie rejet des ZFE aussi fort de
tous ces éléments les objectifs de fin
de vente des véhicules terminent après
2035 vous semble-t-il et s'il vous plaît
répondez-moi sereinement objectivement
et honnêtement toujours
pouvoir être atteint merci madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
avec beaucoup de questions
merci madame la Présidente et je prends
volontairement 4 secondes pour remercier
très honnêtement très sincèrement parce
que c'est quand même ma façon d'être et
d'être honnête et d'être sincère
la bienveillance de madame la Présidente
qui m'a permis de retrouver mon souffle
et la gentillesse des sénatrice qui
m'ont offert quelques pastilles et de
quoi reprendre mon souffle je ne vous
cache pas qu'en six ans de parlementaire
et de ministres je j'ai rarement été
entouré d'entendre bienveillance donc je
prends 15 secondes et pas 15 minutes
pour vous en remercier très sincèrement
ouais mais c'est qu'est-ce que vous
voulez c'est que je perds mon souffle
des idées qui mais juste merci
pardonnez-moi
non non mais c'est pas parce qu'on n'est
pas toujours d'accord qu'on est obligé
en plus fumer devant d'être dur les uns
avec les autres donc merci
bon sur le constat
je l'ai dit à la sénatrice du Var il y a
quelques instants ça n'est pas parce
qu'on a pris un petit peu de retard sur
l'installation des bornes dans un
contexte assez difficile lié et vous
l'avez mentionné monsieur le sénateur
aussi à la pénurie de semi-conducteur à
une inae complexe d'ailleurs surtout les
intrants que ce soit dans le milieu
artisanal comme dans le milieu
industriel qu'on n'arrivera pas à viser
l'objectif d'ailleurs je partage avec
vous le fait que sur la pénurie des
semi-conducteurs et le ministre de
l'industrie et de l'économie s'ils sont
attelés il y aura déjà du mieux il y
aura du mieux en 2023 on s'y est on s'y
est appelé tout au long de l'année
précédente et je rappelle quand même sur
les bornes que nous sommes le troisième
pays d'Europe vous m'avez demandé une
réponse sincère honnête et
l'estimation d'un parc électrique à 20%
en 2030 avec 8 millions de véhicules et
à 45% en 2035 avec 18 millions de
véhicules me semble possible
sans faire référence à d'autres débats
en cours pour le coup à l'assemblée
avant qu'il n'arrive ici je crois qu'en
matière de flux nous pouvons y arriver
si on n'oublie pas ce que j'ai dit au
tout début qui est le rétrofit
c'est-à-dire notre capacité à
transformer aussi des véhicules
thermiques en électrique pas uniquement
à construire de l'électrique mais aussi
à investir sur le rétrofit et la
transformation donc honnêtement
sereinement j'y crois merci Monsieur
Tabarro vous avez 11 secondes
la ministre m'a pas répondu sur les ZFE
mais de toute manière c'est un sujet
qu'on aura dans les mois et les années à
venir malheureusement quand la remise en
place particulièrement difficile sur les
territoires merci merci
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur Joël
Bigot
madame la présidente madame la ministre
la décision de l'Union européenne
d'interdire la vente de véhicules
thermiques neufs horizon 2035 est en
train de bouleverser le marché
automobile selon un rapport récent de la
Fédération des acteurs de la mobilité
électrique les prévisions de croissance
sont exponentielles électriques
passeraient de 1,5 % du parc français
roulant à 24% en 2035 néanmoins c'est
engouement est tempéré par le
déploiement difficile des bornes de
recharge qui sont toujours en deçà de
l'objectif des cent mille fixés par le
gouvernement pour 2022 mais vous avez
répondu tout à l'heure à Monsieur
corbizet que cet objectif serait atteint
en 2023 dont acte à l'heure de la
planification écologique où est le rôle
de l'État dans le déploiement des bornes
de recharge et de manière équilibrée sur
l'ensemble du territoire c'est une
condition sinequanone du développement
de l'électrique quand on quand
l'autonomie des véhicules électriques ne
dépasse pas les 300 km c'est un
véritable enjeu en région Centre Val de
Loire ou encore en Pays de Loire où
cette dernière ne compte que
les principaux de recharge pour 100000
habitants ce qui est très en deçà de la
moyenne nationale comment l'État
entendit l'assurer une répartition
équilibrée du réseau sur l'ensemble du
territoire y a-t-il une attention
particulière portée au territoire peu
dense afin de garantir l'égalité
territoriale et un maillage intelligent
83% de nos concitoyens vivent en zone
rurales et sont donc contraintes par le
manque d'offres de mobilité alternative
pour utiliser quotidiennement leur vie
leur voiture individuelles aussi le
gouvernement prévoit-il un plan
spécifique de soutien l'électrification
des mobilités du quotidien pour ces
zones rurales une enveloppe de 10
millions a été débloquée en fin d'année
dernière mais on est encore bien loin
des besoins locaux identifiés par
l'Insee dans les zones rurales et
périurbaines contrairement aux idées
reçues je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur
dont acte nous aurons nos 100000 bornes
en fin d'année 2023 dans un contexte que
vous connaissez aussi bien que moi
c'est un retard je reste honnête de
sénateurs en sénateur je pense que c'est
un retard qui peut s'entendre si ce
n'est ce comprendre ce qui est important
c'est qu'on arrive à l'objectif voir
qu'on le dépasse le plus vite possible
et quand on voit les chiffres on y
arrivera le sujet que vous mentionnez
est absolument majeur et j'en ai j'ai
essayé du moins de commencer à y
répondre lors d'une question précédente
il est indispensable que les
collectivités locales jouent leur rôle
dans cette planification territoriale
pour cela d'abord sur le volet recharge
station de recharge rappelle que là on
parle pas 10 millions d'euros l'appel à
projet qui a été lancé dans le cadre de
France 2030 c'est 300 millions d'euros
pour justement assurer une intensité
d'aide plus importante dans les
territoires pour les installer des
stations dans les territoires qui sont
situés en dehors des dix principales
métropoles urbaines par ailleurs je le
redis la banque des territoires est aux
côtés des collectivités territoriales et
proposent différents dispositifs
d'accompagnement financiers pour
justement accompagner nos collectivités
territoriales les délégataires de
collectivités les bailleurs notamment
dans cette planification territoriale
enfin l'État est aux côtés des acteurs
locaux dont l'engagement est essentiel
plutôt 60% des bornes aujourd'hui
ont été installés je le répète sous la
maîtrise d'ouvrage de collectivité ou
d'établissements publics et la
réalisation de schémas directeur dédié
va permettre aux acteurs locaux d'être
moteur dans le déploiement de ces
infrastructures je rappelle enfin vous
le connaissez le fond vert doté de 2
milliards d'euros dont
nous pourrions imaginer si les volonté
de la représentation nationale et
celle-ci qu'on isole peut-être une
petite partie sur cette masse des 2
milliards d'euros peut-être pour
renforcer la problématique de du
développement des recharges mais aussi
des infrastructures dans les
collectivités territoriales pourquoi pas
en parler directement avec le ministre
BECHU c'est une option qu'on pourrait
regarder et je vous remercie
merci alors vous avez 112 secondes
monsieur Bigot oui je vous remercie
le ministre Béchu donc je pourrais poser
directement la question mais en tout cas
quand vous avez une course depuis 300 km
à faire et vous habitez une zone peu
dense vous hésitez à prendre votre
véhicule électrique donc c'est une
urgence
merci alors la parole est à Madame
Véronique delsabro merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre comme l'on
dit précédemment mes collègues en 2035
les concessionnaires automobiles ne
pourront plus mettre de véhicules
thermiques neuf en vente je m'en réjouis
pour deux raisons la première à
écologique et la seconde et que cette
mesure répond aux attentes des
territoires ruraux que je me permets de
représenter aujourd'hui à condition
qu'il y ait des infrastructures les
habitants des zones rurales sont
fortement dépendants de leur voiture la
crise des gilets jaunes nous a bien
démontré le lourd tribu payé par les
usagers dépendant des énergies fossiles
rouler à la campagne coûte plus cher
qu'en ville sauf peut-être si on dispose
d'un véhicule électrique à la campagne
le développement des infrastructures de
recharge va jouer un rôle majeur en
matière de mobilité or force est de
constater que le déploiement des bornes
de recharge et laborieux dans nos
régions rurales c'est pourtant une
condition sinequanone du développement
de la mobilité nous voy certes fleurir
des initiatives territoires par
territoires par l'action de l'ensemble
des collectivités parfois de concert je
vous l'accorde la France des 35 000
communes ne doit pas devenir celle des
35 000 abonnements nécessaires pour
accéder aux 35000 bornes de recharge des
véhicules accessibles au public madame
la ministre pensez-vous que le
déploiement des bornes de recharge
constitue le véritable enjeu de
développement et d'aménagement du
territoire si oui quel rôle est place
l'état entend-il tenir dans la question
majeure de l'interopérabilité notamment
en matière de
transparence des tarifs merci
merci madame la ministre
j'éviterai d'être madame la sénatrice
superfétatoire j'ai répondu il y a
quelques instants je crains que vous ne
vous lâchiez et je vous offre à l'aune
de la générosité des sénateurs et des
sénatrices et de leurs bienveillance le
reste de mon temps parce que j'ai déjà
répondu sur les bornes et je n'ai pas
beaucoup d'éléments à ajouter merci
Madame delfabron il vous reste 32
secondes souffre à répondre sur la
transparence je vais juste vous vous
parlez de mon expérience puisque il y a
quelques semaines on va dire au mois de
décembre j'étais encore merdes une
commune rurale de 360 habitants et
vice-président d'une communauté de
communes dans un souci écologique j'ai
acheté un véhicule électrique regardez
il me faut je ne sais pas combien de
cartes pour pouvoir recharger mon
véhicule sur le territoire de plus sur
une même borne avec trois cartes j'ai
des tarifs totalement différents qui
vont de 35 centimes à 15 euros la preuve
à la pluie qu'en dites-vous madame si
[Applaudissements]
les enjeux sont trop importants pour que
nous ne fassions que jouer au jeu de la
minute j'en dis que c'est pas une option
madame la sénatrice Jean dit que je
comprends votre agacement forte agréable
d'ailleurs et je vous remercie d'être
resté agréable
en parlant de transparence vous êtes
très sympathique c'est un vrai sujet
j'ai pas l'expérience que vous avez j'ai
je ne suis que député de Paris et je
n'ai pas l'expérience de la commune
rurale que vous avez c'est pas normal et
ça doit être un sujet je n'ai pas en
charge cette immense périmètre le mien
est déjà mouse costaud pour la référence
mais je pense que c'est un sujet qui
doit être urgemment traité et je suis à
votre disposition pour le faire passer à
notre mise de la transition énergétique
Madame Agnès
une option qui est autant d'opacité et
surtout autant de cartes et autant de
manque de praticité dans ces pratiques
qu'on veut développer
si je peux permettre madame
c'est moi qui redonne la parole juste
donc si vous voulez vous avez une minute
pour répondre excusez-moi madame la
Présidente c'est ma première question
donc il faut que je me plie à l'exercice
madame
madame la ministre lors de votre venue
en Meurthe-et-Moselle je serai ravi
qu'on échange sur ce sujet
ainsi la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
sotarel
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre Carlos Tavarez directeur
général de steelantis tente depuis de
nombreux mois de casser les idées reçues
sur les voitures électriques il n'est
pas le seul mais nul ne semble
l'entendre d'abord en raison de la très
mauvaise empreinte carbone liée à la
fabrication des batteries électriques un
véhicule électrique doit rouler 70 000
km pour commencer à être positif sur le
plan environnemental par rapport à
véhicule thermique ensuite la production
m'a véhicule électrique est plus
onéreuse que celle d'un véhicule
thermique environ 50% de plus avec
aujourd'hui un minimum quasiment de
30000 euros la différence n'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait les classes
moyennes françaises ont-elles vraiment
les moyens de supporter cette différence
nous ne pourrons continuer à faire des
chèques qui bénéficient à notre
essentiellement à l'industrie automobile
chinoise nous l'avons dénoncé lors de
l'examen du PLF
la question du réseau de bornes
électriques largement été évoquée reste
aussi un grand sujet d'inquiétude
partout en France bien sûr mais
peut-être plus encore sur les aires
d'autoroute pour accueillir
simultanément beaucoup de véhicules
enfin et sans parler de notre production
électrique tant en quantité que au
niveau du cou il y a le sujet de
l'emploi et de la mutation profonde et
rapide de notre industrie automobile
avec tout ceci on prépare un gigantesque
plan social pour l'industrie française
il y aurait donc beaucoup de questions
je vais me limiter à deux que
comptez-vous faire pour défendre nos
entreprises et nos emplois par rapport à
l'avancée du monde du véhicule
électrique qui eux aussi une opportunité
j'en conviens et surtout même si je suis
un élu de la ruralité comment
envisagez-vous l'accueil d'un parc tout
électrique sur les aires d'autoroute
demain je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur Sautarel première question
déjà un soutien massif de l'État je le
rappelle même si
on peut se lasser en sortant de la
période du quoiqu'il en coûte mais ça
n'est quand même pas anodin 5 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre de France 2030
dont je le redis 1 milliard d'euros
directement fléchés pour soutenir nos
sous-traitants et pour certains
l'évolution de nos sous-traitants qui
vont être aussi impactés par le
développement des véhicules électriques
deuxième réponse monsieur le sénateur
à l'aune de ce que j'ai dit il y a
quelques instants et vous aurez ce débat
et je sais que vous serez force de
proposition il nous faut trouver les
voies et moyens pour que ce soit nos
entreprises européennes qui bénéficient
du développement de ces véhicules
électriques Bruno Le Maire prépare en ce
moment avec Roland Lescure le projet de
loi réindustrialisation verte on n'est
pas ici dans de l'utopie on est vraiment
sur le réel du semestre du 1er semestre
2023 je ne doute pas que vous serez très
prochainement si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas associé pour pour y travailler et
nous travaillons à des critères je ne
rentrerai pas plus dans les débats dans
le cadre de cet échange mais je ne doute
pas que Bruno Le Maire le fera nous
travaillons à des critères pour faire en
sorte que comme les américains le font
comme l'Asie ne se prive pas de faire on
puisse aussi encourager l'achat de nos
véhicules européens sur le territoire
européen il me semble que c'est la
meilleure façon aussi de soutenir nos
entreprises au-delà du soutien direct de
l'état du plan France 2030 votre
dernière question est très importante
législatives aux autoroutes et
l'installation de bandes de recharge sur
le réseau routier national d'abord on a
consacré une enveloppe de 100 millions
d'euros au développement des stations de
recharge vous le savez ce dispositif a
permis d'équiper 3800 points de recharge
tout au long du réseau routier national
en visant une station tous les 60 km sur
le réseau concédé sur le réseau routier
national concédé environ 85 % des airs
de service sont d'ores et déjà équipés
et elles devraient toutes lettres à 100%
courant 2023 mais monsieur sotarel vous
avez 23 secondes
merci madame la ministre pour ces
éléments de réponse effectivement je
reviens pas sur la dimension
industrielle qu'on aura l'occasion de
réévoquer par ailleurs je me posais
juste une question sur les airs
d'autoroute au-delà de leur équipements
c'est sur les surfaces qui seront
nécessaires parce que je m'interroge sur
le calcul avait été fait par rapport au
nombre de véhicules en période de pointe
et le temps de recharge par rapport au
temps de remplissage d'un réservoir et
les objectifs de la zéro
artificialisation de l'aide par ailleurs
si elle est pas falloir étendre
considérablement nos aires d'autoroute
merci
votre point me semble important donc je
n'ayant pas forcément toutes les
réponses à tout
peut-être pas très la plus compétente
mais je pense que c'est un point
important
alors je sais pas si vous habitez comme
monsieur le sénateur pas très loin de
Christophe Béchu pour le poser la
question mais ce que je sais c'est que
le ministre des Transports et le
ministre de la transition écologique
travaille main dans la main ce que vous
pointez monsieur le sénateur est un vrai
sujet possiblement même un angle mort et
je suggère que la question et je suis à
votre disposition s'il faut faire passer
la question mais soit posé assez
rapidement au cabinet des ministres que
je viens de mentionner c'est un vrai
sujet
la parole est à Monsieur Jacques gros
Perrin
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues en octobre 2022 le
directeur général de stellantis Carlos
Alvares n'était pas très tendre avec
l'Union européenne concernant la montée
en puissance de la voiture électrique
chinoise en Europe
il affirmait que l'offensive chinoise
était attendu et qui c'est l'Europe qui
a provoqué les conditions d'une très
rude bataille ces propos étaient les
suivants si l'Europe ne veut pas que son
industrie automobile disparaisse d'ici
2035 il faut la protéger nous nous
refusons pas la compétition nous voulons
uniquement des conditions équitables
pour se battre contre les Chinois en
fait travailler sur la production verte
d'électricité ensuite sur le réseau puis
alors seulement sur les véhicules
totalement électriques il ajoutait la
décision dogmatique de ne vendre que des
électriques en 2035 à des conséquences
sociales inacceptables la couche de
dogme doit être complétée par la couche
de pragmatisme même Thierry Breton
commissaire européen mis en doute la
faisabilité de l'échéance de bit35
sénateur du tout territoire
particulièrement impacté je m'interroge
sur cette échéance les conséquences
économiques et sociales comme d'autres
régions ne sont pas réellement mesurées
la fragilité de tous les prévisionnels
elle absence d'études publiques d'impact
sérieux ajoute à ce grand point
d'interrogation une telle marche forcée
ne peut avoir pour conséquence une
destruction massive d'emplois je passe
je parle en particulier pour le doux et
le bassin automobiliste sociaux
Montbéliard c'est dès aujourd'hui qu'il
faut s'interroger dans disons elle sera
trop tard le défi est immense coup
fabrication chez une valeur métaux rares
je vais témoigner ici au Sénat de la
grande inquiétude de tout un territoire
et de leurs habitants ainsi que du monde
économique des sous-traitants mais aussi
des élus le gouvernement ne peut se
satisfaire devant ses inquiétudes de
quelques aides ponctuelles et
inaccessibles à beaucoup ou d'un système
subventionné trop complexe comment
madame la ministre pouvez-vous les
rassurer
merci madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur
il y a des éléments et il y a
effectivement les prises de parole que
vous êtes nombreux à citer de président
Carlos navares il y a des doutes que
vous mentionnez et j'en parlais il y a
pas si longtemps avec le commissaire
breton
aujourd'hui on a un taux de pénétration
des véhicules chinois estimés à 18% en
à 8% 5% aujourd'hui 18% en 2025 donc les
chiffres corroborent l'analyse pour
autant et c'est l'objet de tout ce que
j'ai essayé de partager avec vous on est
en train pas demain pas en 2025 mais on
est en train de travailler à bâtir toute
une filière avec des soutiens massifs
d'État je le redis 5 milliards
directement dans le cadre de France 2030
dont encore une fois un milliard
spécifiquement dédié monsieur le
sénateur à nos sous-traitants dont je
sais que dans votre circonscription ils
sont nombreux par ailleurs compte tenu
de l'ampleur du mouvement à opérer
compte tenu de l'ensemble de ses effets
de bord des effets domaines et des
risques que je ne nie pas que le
gouvernement ne nie pas je rappelle
une clause de revoyure est prévue en
aussi pour d'autres technologies à
faible émission comme les carburants
alternatifs qui pourraient comme
certains d'entre vous l'ont suggéré tout
à l'heure peut-être aussi renforcer un
peu le mix énergétique et ne pas le
laisser uniquement reposer sur
l'électrique donc la clause de revoyure
elle est prévue en 26 et en attendant
2026 nous avançons nous bâtissons
véritablement pas uniquement sur les
batteries et c'est aussi le sens de mes
interventions mais sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne de valeur on parlait de lithium
il y a quelques minutes sur les métaux
critiques nous nous dotons au sein de
l'État aussi d'une organisation et on
verra à la clause de revoyure mais
j'entends vos doutes merci vous avez 7
secondes pas une de plus
non je remercie la ministre pour sa
réponse mais ça monte véritablement que
l'Europe a fait tout à l'envers en
imposant les district automobile de
produire des véhicules électriques si
rapidement merci
la parole est quand même Laurence
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre l'Union européenne a interdit à
partir de 2035 la vente de véhicules
neufs à moteur essence ou diesel 450
millions d'Européens sont concernés nous
sommes les seuls à avoir fait ce choix
ni les États-Unis ni le Japon ou la
Chine ne se fixe de tels objectifs en
misant tout sur l'électrique
Carlos Tavares encore lui directeur
général de stellantis à lui-même déclaré
la voiture électrique c'est un choix
politique qui aura des conséquences
économiques sociales et même
environnementale négatives nous refusons
d'être tenus pour responsable dans 10
ans pour un choix que l'Europe nous a
imposé la solution réaliste réside selon
lui dans le véhicule hybride avis
partagé par le patron de Toyota qui nous
alerte également sur les chimères du
tout électrique sur le plan social
d'abord nous l'avons vu le véhicule
coûte trop cher et sa production
entraîne la disparition des activités
sous-traitante artisanale ou
industrielle ensuite sur le plan
économique cette industrie implique un
investissement public lourd nous l'avons
entendu pour équiper le pays à la
mobilité tout électrique à cela il faut
ajouter les subventions à l'achat enfin
avec la flambée du prix de l'électricité
les concessionnaires nous le confirment
la chute des ventes a été brutales au
cours du troisième trimestre 2022 sur le
plan environnemental enfin il s'agit
d'une fausse promesse pour obtenir une
tonne de lithium il faut un million de
litre d'eau plus grave nous savons que
les conditions d'extraction loin de
l'Europe sont inhumaines dangereuses et
polluantes alors madame la ministre pour
les alternatives sérieuses existent
comme l'hydrogène les biocarburants ou
le carburant synthétique des carbonés
qui permettent de conserver les moteurs
thermiques en 2035 elles seront viables
pourquoi ne pas avoir laissé le temps
aux industriels européens de les
développer
merci même la ministre
merci madame la Présidente de multiples
questions abordées je rappelle quand
même ce que je disais dans ma dans ma
prise de parole initiale
aujourd'hui si on veut si on se refixe
le l'objectif de neutralité carbone à
2000 50 on peut aussi d'ailleurs
remettre en question tout est à vocation
à être possiblement remise en question
il y a un moment
la planète elle ne se posera plus de
questions et les futurs générations non
plus mais je suis je sais pas si vous me
connaissez plutôt modéré en la matière
mais je rappelle quand même l'ampleur
aussi du de la bascule qu'on a mené
ensemble et comment arriver à cette
neutralité carbone européenne en faisant
fi d'un secteur des transports qui est
massivement émetteur je la rappelle d'au
moins 30% des des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre les commentaires des
présidents de structure automobile
relèvent des commentaires et je n'ai pas
à les commenter en l'occurrence et
chacun à son point de vue moi j'ai à
cœur de vous rappeler quand même que
même si elle pollue moins la voiture
hybride elle peut lui quand même elle
peut lui tout de même j'ai aussi à coeur
de rappeler que les porteurs de messages
parce que tout transport motorisé pollu
vous le savez quel que soit son mode de
propulsion mais les porteurs de messages
négatifs sur le véhicule électrique ne
prennent souvent en considération qu'une
partie du cycle de vie et non pas sa
globalité concentre uniquement sur le
CO2 la fabrication d'un véhiculé
électrique elle demande plus d'énergie
vous l'avez mentionné du fait de la
production de la batterie pour l'instant
et vous avez été nombreux à le dire les
batteries sont majoritairement produites
en Chine mais aussi en Pologne
pays dans le mix qui a énergétique reste
très carboné et donc c'est pourquoi on
se bat on construit les mégas usines de
batterie électrique c'est pourquoi d'ici
2027 on devrait être autosuffisant pour
équiper nos véhicules électriques
fabriqués en France et qu'on pourra
ensuite possiblement les exporter je
vois pas bien comment on arrive à une
neutralité carbone horizon 2050 sans
s'attaquer au sujet du véhicule
thermique et donc sont fixés des
ambitions que j'entends que vous vieilli
réaliste et encore c'est la liberté de
commenter et d'avoir son avis je vous en
remercie merci alors pour sur le débat
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
Husson pour le groupe les républicains
pour 5 minutes
merci Madame merci Madame la présente
Madame le Ministre le tout électrique
est réalisable en 2035 j'ai l'impression
que on aurait pu changer un terme en
disant est-ce souhaitable
tant les points de vue et je vous
remercier les différents intervenants et
évidemment bien sûr madame la ministre
puisqu'on a eu à la fois des points de
vue très concrets des questions et des
réponses les questions pertinentes et
des réponses étayées mais on voit que
dans le double objectif d'avoir une
production automobile décarbonée et de
lutter contre la pollution automobile il
y a encore un vrai travail y compris en
termes de meilleures connaissances et je
terminerai par là de mon propos dans
quelques instants sur l'analyse du cycle
de vie à la fois de la production
automobile et de son utilisation alors
le elle concentre aujourd'hui les défis
les plus importants me semble-t-il de la
transition écologique économique et du
lien avec la liberté auquel nous sommes
partis aument attachés de pouvoir nous
déplacer en conséquence de quoi oui bien
sûr il faut verdir le parc automobile
vous avez vous êtes tous rentrés dans
cette logique avec
plus ou moins d'envie en tous les cas
certains étant moins jusqu'au-boutiste
d'autres notamment par rapport à la date
coup près de 2035 où je crois nous
devons entendre d'ores et déjà les
interrogations je ne crois pas
effectivement à titre personnel non plus
qu'il faille s'orienter vers une seule
technologie ça n'est jamais bon
notamment lorsque
cette technologie vient à rencontrer des
difficultés la création d'une filière
industrielle
avec différentes étapes et notamment en
espérant un bon aménagement du
territoire par les unités de production
a été madame la ministre à mon avis a
juste titre rappelé avec d'une certaine
manière une triptyque besoin de
formation
qualifiée à tous les échelons une
production automobile si possible
française est européenne et donc une
capacité
d'exportation de notre production pour
servir évidemment notre balance
commerciale qui soit dit en passant en a
grandement besoin et la filière
automobile perd des parts de marché
actuellement et puis c'est un enjeu de
mobilité propre qui passe par
l'exposé par cette liberté à laquelle
nous sommes attentifs mais notamment par
un maillage territorial ou à la fois il
faut disposer
d'unité de recharge à travers le pays là
où il y a de grands flots de circulation
on pense aux air la route mais également
un peu à l'instar de ce qui existait il
y a quelques décennies à travers la
France où il y avait beaucoup de
stations essence nous avons besoin de
nous aurons besoin pour la mobilité
électrique d'être au plus près des
territoires pour ça la date je l'ai dit
de 2035 plusieurs d'entre vous je pense
notamment au sénateur Chauvet qui était
le premier à nous alerter attention de
ne pas en faire une date coupée par un
choix technologique exclusif qui
pourrait d'ailleurs être hâtif raison
pour laquelle je veux le redire il faut
regarder de près à la fois les
biocarburants le rétrophile vous l'avez
dit mais également l'hydrogène un panel
de solutions me semble préférable et
puis le défi qui est devant nous il est
aussi je le disais celui de la de
l'aménagement du territoire qui doit
concilier la transition écologique la
justice sociale mais aussi la réussite
économique dans tous les territoires ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut des
des usines évidemment vous l'avez
compris j'entends le Nord mais voilà
chacun défend la fois son territoire et
je crois que là aussi il faut il faudra
imaginer avec une certaine forme
d'intelligence collective enfin je
voudrais peut-être rappeler que dans ces
filières autour de l'automobile il y a
pas que la production il y a ensuite la
mise sur le marché et l'entretien et il
va falloir déployer sur le territoire là
aussi formation unité pour pouvoir
entretenir et réparer ce sont des
formations nouvelles on y est pas
aujourd'hui donc il y a un travail à
faire et enfin je l'avais dit je veux
terminer sur le sujet qui à mon avis
résume parfaitement au final derrière
l'enjeu économique qui est l'enjeu
écologique de l'analyse du cycle de vie
de la production des véhicules
électriques et des batteries c'est
majeur le gouvernement ne peut pas
s'exonérer aujourd'hui de mettre ses
réflexions en partage avec la
représentation nationale de telle
manière que les orientations qui seront
définitivement arrêtées répondent aux
besoins d'aujourd'hui madame la
Présidente je voulais enfin vous
remercier de votre rigueur souriante
vous avez une parfaite maîtresse des
horloges un grand merci
[Rires]
ou c'est pas la peine de me dire ça pour
me prendre quelques secondes quand même
je vais suspendre quelques instants la
séance pour permettre à chacun de
s'installer pour le prochain point à
l'ordre du jour la science est suspendue